everyone
uh it's uh my great pleasure to uh share
this
new session today and we continue with a
great lineup of speakers uh so uh my uh
co-organizer uh is the next speaker and
uh actually i'm sure he will be happy to
acknowledge that uh the tribute that we
got from yelena was not really well
deserved she did organize the entire
workshop i was she did an amazing job
um so yeah so uh i our next speaker uh
requires no introduction obviously uh we
have centos vimpala who's an expert on
many uh sampling
algorithms in particular on sampling
from convex bodies and today's gonna
give us a very welcome status report so
i'm not gonna take much of his time
thank you thank you
yeah
um
yeah this is uh based on joint work with
many people and i'll mention them as we
go through the theorems uh please feel
free to interrupt i have a couple of
proofs in case there's time for some of
the more recent ideas but
other questions are welcome uh one thing
i'm going to try to do is okay so let me
start with what the problem is you've
seen it many times but you'll see it
maybe slightly more generally
what you have is access to an integrable
function f so you can evaluate it at any
point and you have an initial point
where the function value is is it's also
non-negative
your function value is strictly positive
and an error parameter and you want to
output a point from a distribution whose
distance to be defined how you want what
distance
is with an epsilon of the
density with proportional to f
right so since it's integrable
non-negative you have a density and you
want to be proportional to that that's
the goal
so for example it could be just a
constant over a convex body or
some
nice function restricted to a convex
body or restrict to a set and so on i'm
saying convex because as you'll quickly
see those are the only things we know
how to do
efficiently
so that's a sampling problem
now the ones that we can solve in
polynomial time
are basically
sampling log concave density functions
arbitrary ones no no
strong lock on gravity assumption no
lipschitzness assumptions
um
and or in a special case of that is the
uniform distribution on a given convex
body
so
for these in fact all we need is a
membership oracle for the set or a value
oracle x what's the value of f f at that
point that's it no other no gradient no
hessian this is all you might have
and of course if you have an explicit
polytope then everything is explicit
there's
and you're talking about the uniform
distribution or
some explicit function over this
why do you want to do this
uh donate you can do using sampling you
can compute volume center of gravity
covariance
you can do robust online private
optimization
model exploration learning
but maybe most interestingly it seems to
provide a new lens
to understand convexity and optimization
and also the model of computation itself
what can you do or not do
in this model
okay so
um the first quick segment is going to
be about a few ways to sample
maybe the most successful ones but i
want to make one remark that throughout
the talk i will try to avoid using the
k word okay
and you can guess what the k word is
okay so we will talk about polynomial
time algorithms
okay so how to sample
uh well the ball walk
uh at a point x
you
pick a random point in a ball of fixed
radius delta
and if it's in the set you go there
otherwise try again
okay so this is a symmetric process x to
y is the same as y to x the pdf and
the stationary distribution is therefore
uniform it's a discrete time version of
brownian motion with reflection of the
boundaries
you can view it like that
another process is hit and run
so uh this was uh suggested by bonnet
and smith the bonnet is the father of
um the cryptographer at stanford
and smith around the same time
uh
he was an operations researcher and they
say at a point x pick a random chord
through this point x
so you can its endpoints are determined
by the body
and then on this just go to uniform
random point
okay now to find the endpoints you can
do a binary search you don't have to be
exactly there as long as you have
something that contains it let's say
twice as long you do you pick uniformly
and just check if you're in or not so
you don't you don't waste much time
doing this it's essentially the same as
a membership test
and you don't have any delta parameter
you don't have a step size parameter so
that's nice you don't have to figure out
what step size to use in the ball walk
again it's symmetric in the station
distribution uniform and yeah
now a version of this that's popular in
practice
and in many instances beats just doing
hit and run is to do this but instead of
picking a random
unit vector you just pick one of the
axis directions and that's coordinated
and run and we saw talk earlier in the
week about this
this is
preferable because the per step
complexity turns out to be much lower
yes
you pick uniformly a point on this unit
sphere
and you go in that direction from the
current point x
that's right yes
yeah so there is no guarantee that the
one step distribution is uniform the one
step distribution is highly skewed
the only thing you need to get reach the
correct distribution is that the process
is symmetric now look at if you go from
x to y the probability of going from x
to y is the same as going from y to x
why because the probability of choosing
this direction is the same for both and
once you've chosen this direction the
length of the chord through them is
obviously the same it's the same chord
and so you can show that the the process
is symmetric and that's all you need to
guarantee that you converge to uniform
distribution
right
the one yeah by the way uh both these
walks are easily extended to general
functions f by simply sampling from the
restriction to the to the chord in this
case
okay so and then another work dimension
is the dick and walk we also saw this
and this is only for polytopes
and at each point x you define this
dicken ellipsoid which is
this ellipsoid defined using the
constraints the summation the weighted
sum of a i ai transpose if ai is a
constraint rho
and it's fully contained in the body at
every point x
and what you do is
if if you pick uniformly from this
ellipsoid if the point you go to has the
property that uh its ellipsoid contains
x
then uh then you go there with this
with with with the with uh you don't
necessarily go there you go there with
probability proportional to the ratio of
these volumes
again the point of this step is is is
this metropolis filter is to make sure
that the the distribution is uniform
because the volumes of the ellipsoids
could be quite different even at a short
distance
okay so that's uh that's the third
process
um in the explicit case
and then a fourth one is a hamiltonian
monte carlo it uh it's significantly
different from the other ones in that
the steps are not straight lines
this is an actual plot over a simplex
and uh you know each each step is is is
potentially a curve you know so you look
join you have in addition to the
position x you also have a velocity v
and each step is going to be in the
space of x v and it will be uh
you pick a random v that's still the
same it's supposed to represent the
direction which you want to go
but rather than going straight we'll
follow a curve given by the ode of the
hamiltonian okay i think there were
talks about this in the boot camp and
a little bit in
andres talk and so on
so to sample according to some function
we can actually set up the hamiltonian
to be basically equal to the
to the function in the exponent
and then we have the flexibility of
choosing this g
for now let's say you pick g to be the
identity so this is just length of v
squared and that's a constant
then all you're doing is picking a
random velocity at each step according
to a you know a gaussian and then you're
moving along the solution of this curve
uh either one way or the other way up to
for a certain time so certain distance
yeah that's that's the process
okay why this is interesting or better
we'll worry about a little bit later
so those are the
the processes right ball walk hit and
run coordinate and run they can walk
hamiltonians sort of the competitors
in this in this in this game
so look at these cases general law
concave absolutely no assumptions
gaussian in a convex body arbitrary
convex body okay
uniform in a convex body and uniform in
a polytope
okay here everything is explicit here
you have some access to the function
here you have access to the body the
gaussian is explicit and here again you
have access to the function
so these are the this is the state of
the art
so here i'm writing the the number of
steps
whatever process you're using it you're
going to use some number of steps and
this is the the complexity first step
for earth the number of arithmetic
operations you might need to do per step
okay so there are n to the four
membership calls but in addition per
membership call you have to do n squared
work to maintain everything it's
basically a matrix that uh that doesn't
find transformation
a linear transformation so that's that's
that's that's the current status of log
concave sampling with no assumptions
okay so clearly
if you want to work on a problem
uh there's one where the bound is
unlikely to be the right answer
okay now uh
uh gaussian in a context body is a
gaussian is a very nice convex
i mean a log concave function but
restricted to the arbitrary convex body
you can do it better n cube and still
per step n squared
uniform in a convex body you can do
slightly
worse than that 3 plus little o 1
and again n squared per step
now when you restrict to polytopes
uh with m in n facets and facet defining
inequalities
in n dimension the complexity becomes m
times n to the little bit less than 3.2
i'm sort of doing a disservice to the
intense activity that happens in the
fourth decimal place of matrix
multiplication but it's it's it's less
than m n to the 3.2
okay
um
okay
and this is all
with no assumptions so you don't have a
warm start you don't have a well-rounded
body you just you're just given this
input and you you've got to give produce
a random point
okay turns out that in this time you can
also compute the volume or integrate
okay you can compute the volume compute
the volume integrate the gaussian
integrate general or concave function
in it's the same time as producing one
first the first sample
okay this second line is from a warm
start
so you already have a distribution
that's uh
that's uh uh somewhat close to the to
the to the to the target distribution
and uh
in in uh in in uh
and in moreover you've uh may apply an
affine transformation to make the body
as nice as you want in particular will
make it isotropic and in this case uh
the the complexity goes down to a little
over quadratic quadratic little over
quadratic and drops by almost a linear
term
okay so that's the state of the art for
for uh sampling these things
now what is the process
the winner in all cases is bulwark
uh for the general law concave hit and
run is as good as bobo
okay i i'm talking about the dependent
the polynomial dependence on the
dimension uh the dependence on the dense
distance to the target is always
logarithmic uh yeah
right so this is this is the
this is the state of the art now there
are what happened to these other
competitors
for uh romanian hamilton monte carlo
here's the status
the number of steps one can prove is m
times n to the two thirds in polytopes
remember we're only going to use it for
polytopes and but the per step
complexity involves solving a linear
system
okay so it's a it's it's this and so
this is way off from even though and
this requires a warm start without a
warm start another factor of n
uh the weighted dick in similarly this
is n squared
but then you have here
this first step is a is a is a linear
solve complexity
and uh and this again these are from
warm starts if you want from a without a
warm start you need to use uh
a factor of end more
okay and one nice thing about these
works however is that you don't need any
rounding these these processes are a
fine invariant
so it's as good as being an isotropic
position from the start
yes
no you can make it log one over epsilon
yeah
yeah exactly yeah so in general for the
ball lock you can make it lock one arm
okay so uh
uh
so to summarize in theory in theory
today ball walk is best at least if
you're talking about polynomial time
algorithms
okay now of course this is today and
yeah and it's in theory
okay now this was built on uh
decades of
progress on sampling
various techniques came up and almost
all of them are used in the analysis of
the
of the final result or the current state
of the art
okay um
so how does convergence work so i want
to spend sort of the next segment on on
uh
some of the ideas that go here and then
uh move to the status status of sampling
in practice
so um
how does convergence work i mean it's
it's uh in in these cases uh coupling
and and contraction are just simply too
weak processes they're they're probably
uh
uh off from the truth
and uh so the word the technique that's
in tight in many cases is conductance
uh this was introduced by
a german sinclair and
adapted generalized to the continuous
setting by lovasen shimnovich
and basically it includes it has two
parts
the first part is to show that your
discrete process if you look at one step
of your discrete process from nearby
points the one step distributions
overlap a lot
now figure out that what at what
distance do you have overlap so it's
coupling but only for one-step
distributions and the second part is a
purely geometric iso perimeter that you
want to say that large subsets
in the stationary measure have large
boundaries
okay so for the ball walk this theorem
goes back already to sun and low as you
know it's
you mentioned quickly that uh coupling
methods are provably
not sufficient for this no they are
they're they're polynomial but they're
they uh they are uh off from the the the
what we know is the right paloma answer
and and and what do you mean by probably
like the um
yeah so there are uh
papers by um so coupling requires uh if
you if you think of it the the most
basic version requires contraction of
of some notion for every pair
in the setup
so that contraction it happens at a
slower rate than convergence to the
stationary right
there is a paper for mixing of
the ball walk in the convex body which
show uses the coupling technique to
prove it and gets at the time an end to
the eighth bound
uh yeah so it's it it suffices for
polynomial but
yeah
so this theorem by conor lawrence
already in 97
says the following
if you apply the ball walk to a near
isotropic distribution so the the second
moments are i mean the variances are all
one or close to one in every direction
arbitrary log concave density and from a
warm start constant factors form start
then it converges in n squared over psi
p squared
where what is this psi p
i'm just going to define it for a convex
body
it's the trigger constant or
isoparametric ratio
uh over all subsets
uh measurable subsets in the in your in
your conex body it's the volume of the
boundary and minus one dimensional
volume of the boundary divided by the
the the volume of the
smaller of the two sides
okay so it's the expansion of the
stationary distribution
so you see we want to prove the
convergence of the markov chain so
you're interested in the trigger
constant or
conductance of the markov chain
and this theorem says
that up to a dimension quadratic and
dimension factor it's determined or it's
upper bounded by the trigger constant of
its stationary distribution
yeah purely okay this is already in 97
and so once you prove this of course you
want to know what is this constant
right and and in the paper they prove
that it is at least one over root n
we'll see in the in a slide
so that's that's so just a minute about
isoprometry we already defined it this
is it for general measures
and for a gaussian it's square root of
two or five is always half spaces
what about other distributions
you know could you hope for half spaces
so general log concave densities
is a nice class because you expect that
you can't have nothing in the middle and
the conjecture says that for any law
concave density in any dimension half
spaces are the minimizers up to a
universal constant
whereas for gaussians they are the
absolute best minimizer
uh for arbitrary log concave densities
half spaces gives you give you the
isotomic ratio up to
a universal constant independent
dimension independent of the body that's
the conjunction
another convenient way to rephrase this
is in terms of the covariance matrix so
if i take the covariance matrix of your
density
the trace is the sum of the eigenvalues
here the theorem of kls
which is used in their sampling paper
says that the constant is at least 1
over
square root of the trace and so in the
isotropic case when a is identity so the
covariance is identity you get constant
over root n
the conjecture is that it only depends
on the largest eigenvalue which would
give you constant in the isotropic case
we improved it with entirely to one over
n to one fourth and
um sort of uh
suggested a scheme for going further but
uh but but uh did not manage to do it
and then last year uh chen
uh uh uh uh
found a
nice way to to to make it all work
and improve the bound to constant over
n to the little one okay so it's it's
about the little is about
um uh
square root of log log n over log n okay
so
okay so we don't yet know the step full
charge of the conjecture but as far as
the
exponent in the
sampling complex to the ball walk is
concerned from a warm start in near
isotropic position it's two plus little
one okay
okay
so
now are these serious issues rounding
and warm start yes they're very serious
issues
uh and so the question is how to make a
body isotropic how to get a warm start
so you can do the following rounding
algorithm
and so here's a different algorithm
might be useful
um
we we have this convex body
and we'll focus on the convex body case
and we have a unit ball inside
and the body itself is contained in some
gigantic capital ball capital of radius
capital r which could be exponentially
large or whatever it's a parameter
okay so what we'll do is consider a
sequence
of balls intersected with the body
right just a sequence of balls
of doubling radius
so the the radius is doubling
and the game will be this well the very
first one obviously is isotropic it's
just the uniform
up to up to scaling and then
you when you doubled it
well it's no longer isotropic
it could be quite far from isotropic
actually but it's guaranteed to be well
rounded
meaning its trace you know the trace
of the eigenvalues the expectation of a
random point's length squared is order n
so if you take
and you know this ball intersected with
the body and it's isotropic and you
double the ball radius
isotropic goes away completely not no
constant it's factor of n uh phenomenal
n but it remains well rounded
so
now to sample a well-rounded body
uh we we can still do that in n q
we can still have r one over root n
because that's really the only bound
that kls used just the fact that the
trace is n so we can do this still in n
cubed
and so you in n cube steps you can get a
sample but you need but but to make it
the new one isotropic so here's the game
you're isotropic go to a bigger one
sample from that get enough samples to
figure out isotropy and repeat
okay now
uh yeah that's that's that how many
samples do you need it's only order n
and this is a very nice result of
um
adam check uh
litwak pior and tom chuck elgerman
okay
uh there were previous uh bounds which
were like n log n by rudelson and n
polylog n by
by bourgane and the bound that kls used
was n squared and they posed the
question can you do it and then and
there was another question posted in the
paper
so the complexity of this algorithm is
log r phases
to complete
n samples per phase and cube
for a sample gives you enter the 4.
okay
so this is higher than than what we have
for sampling sampling was only n to the
two plus little one from a warm start
and isotropy but computing this isotropy
is taking you into the four
so that's one part the other part if you
have an isotropic
uh not estrogen if you just have a
well-rounded body turns out if you just
have a well-rounded body you don't need
isotropic then you can do sampling in um
in cube steps without any warm start
assumption so together they give you end
to the force sampling for any convex
body
so
the question is can we round faster than
n to the four
and this result with herjia aditya ladan
internally says
that any convex body can be brought into
brought into new isotropic position
using n cubed over sine squared
membership force
okay now two things to notice here so
first of all like the kls theorem this
now directly relates the complexity of
rounding and therefore sampling and
without any start assumptions and volume
computation also i'll put that corollary
up so so volume also can be done because
once it's round you know that the volume
is
fast uh
that's one but second this psi is not
the sigh of the particular body
it's the constant
universal for all bodies in that
dimension
all lock on k form so we have changed
from
from you know specific body so the kls
theorem you only need to know the the
the isoparametric ratio of the body you
want to sample
okay whereas uh for this theorem we need
to know the universal bound
on everything in that dimension
fortunately you know we can we
today we have good bounce on this so
this is still n to the 3 plus little one
okay so uh
and then subsequent ones will be fast n
squared over psi k square that's the
care thing
okay so
um
uh now i
how do we do this how can we do this
faster i mean this looked pretty optimal
right you want a double it's
well-rounded you need n samples
so the idea and
uh
is the following
so we need to figure out how to convert
a well-rounded body into an isotropic
body without taking n samples
just too much we can't afford enzymes so
what we're going to do is
we'll start with start small it'll be in
phases we'll start small
the r is the radius of the inner ball
and
we'll take only about r squared log n
samples
now you might think with r squared log n
samples what can you estimate about the
covariance well you can estimate all the
large eigenvalues
okay so you have this body that might
have some large eigenvalues and others
small
and so with few samples you can estimate
the large eigenvalues
it's the small ones that you need a lot
of samples for
so if you estimate just the large ones
then orthogonal to that you know things
are small and you're going to scale up
and that's it that's going to be the
algorithm we'll do this repeatedly
sample k points where k will keep
increasing estimate the covariance using
these k points k is sublinear it's in
the beginning it's just polylog
and then take the subspace of large
eigenvalues with the fixed threshold the
threshold will just be n
and everything in the orthogonal
substrates will scale up by a factor of
two
and we repeat this process
now
uh yeah i'm giving some intuition here
but looking at the clock let me
um
okay so maybe this slide is worth it
so initially we're using coarse
estimates and gradually refining
to estimate the smaller eigenvalues why
is this better
the point is that when we reach finer
estimates
the body will be closer to isotropic
and therefore the sampling will be
faster
so initially we need very few samples
but the body is far from isotropic the
sampling is expensive and cube per step
but only polylog samples
as we go along
we're going to need fewer more samples
but each sample takes less time
and overall it will still be just as if
it's one phase because the number of
phases is still only going to be long
we're doubling still
okay so um
so this is the point we we
we find these skinny directions and
increase them and now the sampling
complexity is this divided by the ball
radius squared
okay i'm going too fast here for this to
make sense but we need one more crucial
ingredient to make this work
because you see if we just use
the the
the
uh isotropy here
i mean the isoparametry here
we the only bound we have is the trace
which is large
so instead of that we'll say if it turns
out
that the
trigger constant this k l s constant is
at least constant over n to the one over
p for some p some p greater than one
then in fact for any log concave density
the trigger constant is at least one
over
square root of
the ph norm of its covariance
you see normally we just put p equal to
one and we have trace
now we're saying if you can get to n to
the one over p you get here you get to
put here the p ethanol
which in general is much smaller
okay so the proof of this is also by the
technique that's used localization the
technique is used for almost all these
are super metric inequalities um
and then the sampling complexity instead
of being n squared times trace is n
squared times p ethanol divided by the
inner ball radius squared
and so uh i won't have time to prove
these lemmas but but this is this this
lays out the entire proof the first
point is that the covariance matrix
pieth norm stays small it doesn't grow
very fast it grows only as a small power
of the inner ball radius
initially it's n and then it grows only
as a small power second
the inner ball
you see you have this this is this may
be the only picture i get to draw
we have this covariance at some point
we estimated this large eigenvalues
and in the orthogonal maybe not exactly
maybe you estimated roughly like that
and in the certain directions we're
scaling up
right so we make it uh something like
that
now you ask here i had a small ball
what's the radius of the ball contained
inside the scaled up body i didn't scale
in all directions if i scale in all
directions by factor of two of course it
goes up by a factor of two i only scaled
in the small eigenvalue directions the
point is it still goes up by a factor of
almost two two two times one minus one
over log n
so the inner ball is almost doubling
um yeah
so that's that's that's that's this part
and since it's almost doubling the trace
stays small with respect to the inner
ball and uh and and also the number of
phases is small
and then finally the number of samples
we need per phase is small to estimate
all the large eigenvalues
okay so that putting that together you
get
the complexities
n cube over sine squared
now these are the proofs of the lemmas
each of them is just one slide but you
can find them in the paper so i will
this was the one i tried to draw here
and the last part which says why do you
need only so many samples inner radius
square samples that uses directly the
matrix turn off bound for independent
samples
right if you have a covariance matrix
and i have an empirical covariance
matrix from k samples
then this is just saying uh
what the deviation bounds are going to
be and those suffice for us
okay these are the bounds in spectral
norm and so we are we're happy with the
deviation of a factor of n
additive because we're only trying to
estimate eigenvalue is bigger than m
and so it it it's enough for us to use
so many samples
that's that's there so so that's this is
this this is what we talked about so far
very quickly but you get a picture of
that
um
okay now we're going to move to practice
for the remaining
six or seven minutes or
all right and you're welcome to
interrupt uh of course
and m is the number of sides right yes
so if the number of sides is low but am
i reading it correctly that rhythm c is
a lot better
no um let's do the thing so let's say m
is order n
okay that should only be favorable
just to
that the first one is end to the 3.3
i mean 4.3
4.2 sorry
and then this is uh bigger it's more
than five so even from a warm start it's
slower
yeah
yeah okay
um
right
good
but
what is the uh issue in mind with issue
the first thing is that for both ball
walk and hit and run even in isotropic
position
your step sizes have to be small they
really have to be small they can only be
one over root n if you make it bigger
than that you're going to step out of
the body most of the time you're wasting
the steps
and this means you really take n squared
steps mix
okay
this is due to the points near the
boundary which is most of them even for
a
hypercube
now here's the state of the art in
practice
this model
is from ronan fleming who spoke
yesterday
about metabolic systems and
systems biology and how they use
sampling there
and this model has uh
uh
so many
you know variables and equations
okay so we want to solve ax equal to b
with bounds on the axis
and uh the dimension is is is you know
more than half a million
um
if they really want to do it okay
zero auto methods like ball walk and hit
and run
take forever i mean this n squared is
too much
even after you reduce the dimension it's
still you're talking about hundred
thousand and square is just too much
existing first order packages don't even
move they can't handle the constraints
okay
so if you go to numpyro or stan
there are actually more and more of
these
working packages yeah so one quick
question in this problem so
you want to sample uniformly from this
polygon with m n
do you have a point in there to start no
you have to find that also okay yeah
they they but in some cases
about zero is a point but they let us
know
but uh but but typically no you you have
to find the initial point
okay yeah so in fact in in the in the um
bounds that i claimed earlier you have
to find the point for the polygon
okay
but now you know we yeah okay so um
right now if you run this which i'm
going to talk about
crunch it takes one hour per sample
from this model so it runs you can even
run it on my laptop or your laptop yeah
and you can sample any polytope in
netlib which is this benchmark that has
served very well for optimization
algorithms because of degeneracies
okay and so
you can you can sample any of those
okay so well how are we doing this not
ball walk
not hit and run
uh uh
it's it's hamilton in monte carlo
for now
so the step size was the bottleneck the
idea of hmc as we already described is
to go to this
xv space
sample accord jointly
and then and then
move according to this ode
so
now hmc itself is going to be slow
because it depends on how skewed the
function is
how skewed the polytube is and and the
function you're trying to sample from
there will be a a a
a k dependence
so
uh nevertheless it allows you to
incorporate local geometry in particular
at each point x you can use a different
gaussian distribution uh given by the
matrix gx sort of a local metric and
sample from that instead and you will
still get the right conditional on x
marginal on x
uh so it's the same problem but the
hamiltonian has changed
um this is motivated very very well by
so what what function should we use we
directly borrow
ideas from the interior point method and
they tell you that the log barrier is a
is a nice function
what it does is
the problem is the boundary right you
get close to the boundary you start
taking small steps
so you kind of get rid of the boundary
by replacing
your uh
your your euclidean space with this with
this hessian manifold in this romanian
manifold where distances scale like that
so you still are able to take steps
uh uh you know pretty long steps in this
space
okay so
uh that's the point so the the
the what we'll use as the local local
metric is the hessian of the log band
okay
so if you do that it turns out it
converges in sub quadratic number of
steps remember bulwark is n squared so
at least when m is order n this is less
than n squared the question was can you
is that even possible
and on the cube
it mixes in
polylog steps
any other of the other methods really
take n steps at least on a hyper avocado
is an easy problem but the point is this
this actually gives you logarithmic
behavior
now however caveat each step may require
solving a linear system you have to
solve this ode
it's no longer just membership test so
there's a couple of problems what's the
best metric to use that's still
efficiently computable and what's the
corresponding careless conjecture in
this hessian manifold setting
okay i
there are candidates but i haven't seen
one that's crisp enough to remember
okay
so uh so but we're not done yet typical
problems have equations that's the issue
and to take care of equations
uh you know we have to work in the
subspace of the equations and the metric
is is the you know so we have pseudo
inverse here
and
and pseudo determinant
okay which looks even more complicated
but uh in fact the hamiltonian becomes
very explicit for equations so so this
is what you have to use at each step
and
what you the most expensive thing you
have to do at each step is a is a
cholesky factorization so if you're
lucky and the chelsea factorization is
fast for your matrix everything runs
really fast and the total number of
steps is just like the integer point
method you know it's 30 or you know 50
something like this
of course in theory it's root n right
and and in this case it's even more it's
m times n to the two thirds
okay so i was going to do a demo but i
think maybe i'll just do that in the
break but this is a package you can find
online and run in matlab uh and uh with
ronan fleming we're
incorporating it in cobra and it's in a
testing phase so that they can use it on
all their
nice metabolic models
there were earlier packages for volume
and sampling
with ben cousins we had one that was
able to do volumes in thousand
dimensional polytopes
in one hour
um uh but not hundred thousand
and then with uh and then uh physical
pillows and emress have a different uh
uh set of uh uh software which uh also
does volume and sampling and they it
works
it's in c plus and they reported better
runtimes for some of the benchmarks
okay so i'll conclude take a minute to
do some open problems
first one does the ball walk mix rapidly
starting at a single deterministic point
like the center of gravity
we don't know
okay
it mixes rapidly from a random point
that's a warm start
so most points are great but what about
the center of gravity or give me one
deterministic point from which you can
guarantee it mix as well
and i'm not talking about n cube mixing
give me n to the hundred mixing
okay
uh
next uh
when do you stop this this question
becomes extremely important in practice
right i haven't written down constants
everything was o and o tilde and o star
right and some of the constants are like
10 to the 10. so when do you stop
and here is one possibility does it
suffice to check
that the measure on just half spaces has
converged rather than or you know
checking convergence and total rational
distance is a complicated thing
you so you come up with some test
functions what about if you check only
on half spaces does that guarantee that
you've converged given the nature of
these processes
of course it's not true in general
because you can imagine a chest bone
right if you only you want a uniform in
a square but if you only fill the black
it looks great for every half space
but
of course how you the point is you would
never reach that if you did a ball walk
and then here is a test that ben cousins
proposed which we actually have in the
package
what you do is you have your convex body
and after you get your sample
you just scale the body you know a
little bit
and check if the fraction of samples in
your scale body is proportional to what
should be the it should be the the
volume scale right alpha to the n 1
minus alpha
just check that that's your test
uh okay
of course how true is the kls conjecture
and on these hessian manifolds and then
finally um if i give you ax less than
equal to b an explicit polytope there's
no reason we need to use randomization
there is a deterministic algorithm to
estimate the volume and what does it
mean for sampling this means that give
me a set of points in here so that with
respect to you know a certain class of
uh uh uh
subsets it's the right measure
right fraction
okay i'll stop here
thank you
thank you for this quick tour uh maybe
we have time for one short question
before we take a break
just give me one second
um so
maybe it's a little bit unrelated
question but still
i feel a bit related so
if you have n samples from a convex body
i mean do you know i mean could you
estimate the trigger constant yeah
cheaply in in this case of convex uh
bodies and could that help in kind of
like determining you know you're close
to convergence i mean if you if you have
produce
n points that you feel are samples and
then you use those guys to try to
estimate i mean is this right yeah it's
a very good question the short answer is
i don't know but it's close related to
what i asked because to determine the
trigger constants it's enough to
determine the expansion for half spaces
up to a constant assuming the conjugate
is true and uh so
is is are n samples enough to determine
the whether you have converged in all
half spaces information theoretically
yes actually by vc dimension arguments
you don't need much more than that
but how do you actually check it
right that's uh that's how do you check
whether uh your n samples are correct
for every half space is it enough to
check random half spaces not clear yeah
and of course i imagine here what is
crucial is that i mean the approximation
should be good for i mean they should
scale with dimension right i mean
this is important right like i mean it's
not like i mean i can i i would be able
to tell you okay there is a way to do
this but then maybe the error in terms
of dimension would be horrible like i
mean right okay yeah you want it to be
sort of the achieve the same
epsilon error using something like n
over epsilon squared samples okay okay
thank you
all right thank you so uh i think we're
gonna stop the question if you have more
questions for uh santosh maybe you can
ask him during our uh quick uh uh
eight minute break he's also going to be
running a demo if you uh once you watch
some cartoon all right let's thank
santosh again
[Music]